Federal Reserve Chairman Ben Bernanke
today said student loan debt does not
pose the same threat to the financial
system that mortgage debt did during the
2008 crisis the Fed Chairman answered
questions today from educators across
the country during a town hall style
meeting that focused on financial
education he also urged state and local
governments to maintain funding for
education in general this is about an
hour
hello everyone and thank you for joining
us here in Washington DC today for a
conversation with Federal Reserve
Chairman Ben Bernanke as he takes
questions from teachers about personal
finance the Federal Reserve and the
economy my name is rose Pianalto and I
work here at the Board of Governors and
I look forward to moderating today's
session here in the boardroom of the
Federal Reserve we are pleased to host a
group of 60 educators who teach
economics and personal finance to young
people we are also joined via
videoconference by educators from all
over the country who are participating
in local events at their regional
reserve banks and branch offices as well
as many who are viewing this exchange
via webcast through this session the
Federal Reserve System seeks to advance
the conversation about the importance of
financial at financial education for
young people we also hope to provide
insights into the Federal Reserve's
goals and activities so we can support
the work you do with students as you
strive to teach them how the decisions
made by the central bank affect them
their families and the economy
throughout our event today twitter users
can follow the Federal Reserve boards
feed at Federal Reserve and join the
discussion about the event by using the
hashtag Fed Town Hall today we are
honored to bring you Federal Reserve
Chairman Ben Bernanke before coming to
the Board of Governors in 2002
Chairman Bernanke was a professor of
economics and public affairs at
Princeton University he also chaired the
Department of Economics from 1996 to
2002
Chairman Bernanke served as a governor
of the Federal Reserve System from 2002
to 2005 in 2005 he became the chair of
the President's Council of Economic
Advisers he returned the Federal Reserve
as the chairman of the board of
governors in 2006
Chairman Bernanke grew up in Dillon
South Carolina
and received a BA in economics from
Harvard University and a PhD in
economics from the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology he and his wife
Anna also an educator have two children
thank you for joining us today mr.
chairman
hi welcome welcome to the Federal
Reserve I'm delighted to have the
opportunity to speak with you today with
educators throughout the country on the
topic of financial education thank you
for your participation and for the very
important work that you do as an
educator myself I understand the
profound effect that good teachers and a
quality education have on the lives of
our young people today I hope you'll
learn from each other and share ways to
best promote learning and in particular
to help students achieve greater
financial literacy financial education
supports not only individual well-being
but also the economic health of our
nation as the recent financial crisis
illustrates consumers who can make
informed decisions about financial
products and services not only serve
their own best interests but
collectively they also help promote
broader economic stability smart
financial planning such as budgeting
saving for emergencies and preparing for
retirement can help households enjoy
better lives while weathering financial
shocks financial education can play a
key role in getting to these good
outcomes research by Federal Reserve
Board staff members and the
effectiveness on financial education for
young military personnel for example
found that those who had taken a high
school financial education course were
more likely to save regularly effective
financial education is not just about
teaching students about financial
products or about performing financial
calculations it also involves teaching
them essential skills and concepts they
will need to make major financial
choices high school students might not
recall specific information about a
lesson from loans a year ago when they
go to get their first car loan or their
first student loan however if they
understand remember some basic ideas for
example that it's important to shop
around for a loan for a low interest
rate to review the fees charged and to
know how to contact financial counselors
and advisors they'll be more likely to
make a good decision a particularly
valuable lesson we can teach
students is how to apply the economic
way of thinking to their decisions for
instance the topic of student loan debt
and whether students are prepared to
service that debt upon graduation has
received increased attention lately
students with some exposure to economic
thinking will be more likely to
conceptualize their spending on
post-secondary education as an
investment in their own human capital
and choose their school course of study
means of paying for their education and
profession with that thought in mind
likewise the economic tool of
cost-benefit analysis should help
students make sound or personal and
financial decisions financial education
also provides a context for students to
develop important skills that can be
applied more broadly making good
financial decisions requires that
consumers seek out relevant information
from trustworthy sources and that they
use critical thinking quantitative
reasoning and decision-making skills
these competencies are also some of the
fundamental abilities that our schools
seek to inculcate in our children as
with other types of education the format
and quality of the content matters a
great deal
providing financial education that is
realistic interesting and relevant can
help students retain information and
remain engaged games and simulations can
be particularly effective at keeping
students interested for example in 2010
I spoke at the opening of the Junior
Achievement finance Park in Fairfax
Virginia this organization as well as
similar facilities throughout the
country allows students to play the role
of a family head with financial
challenges and opportunities giving them
a chance to practice financial decision
making in a realistic setting students
and their parents can become financially
literate together through exercises such
as intergenerational homework
assignments I love that phrase which
reinforced the concepts taught in class
such strategies allow educators to help
adults who until then may not have been
exposed to financial
concepts to provide the most effective
education curriculum should also have
clear standards and goals to that end
the federal government's financial
literacy and Education Commission of
which the Federal Reserve is a member
has identified five core competencies
that should be covered by financial
education earning an income spending
saving and investment borrowing and
protecting behind each of these
competencies is a set of related
knowledge and skills and corresponding
behaviors for example in the category of
earnings and income students are
expected to know the difference between
gross pay and net pay and information
about benefits and taxes with this
knowledge they can understand their pay
stubs and take full advantage of
workplace benefits the five core
competencies are reflected in the
national standards for personal finance
being developed by the Council of
Economic education and several of our
Federal Reserve System colleagues are
working with the council on this project
while it's important to begin teaching
financial skills to children and
teenagers achieving and maintaining
financial know-how is a lifelong
undertaking the types of financial
decisions that people have to make from
paying for school to buying a home to
planning for retirement vary throughout
the course of their lives and thus we
need to ensure that access to financial
education is readily available at all
stages of life
moreover relevant accurate and reliable
financial information must be readily
available to consumers at the very time
that they are making their decisions
given the ubiquity of smartphones
applications for mobile devices may be
one effective method of delivering
just-in-time information at a relatively
low cost for example our colleagues at
the Department of Treasury are currently
running an app contest to design mobile
tools to help Americans make better
financial choices because financially
capable consumers ultimately contribute
to a stable economic and
system as well as improve their own
financial situations it's clear that the
Federal Reserve has a significant stake
in financial education we demonstrate
our commitment through numerous programs
and resources offered by the Federal
Reserve System staff and through
partnerships our reserve banks have
formed with local educators and
institutions for instance the Federal
Reserve Bank of Chicago during its
annual Money Smart Week conducts free
classes and activities to help consumers
better manage their personal finances
and the Federal Reserve Bank of st.
Louis offers a broad selection of online
personal finance courses that teachers
can use along with their students to
find out more about what's happening in
your area I encourage you to visit the
Federal Reserve systems education
website
WWE can all of you for your
participation today
it's a great pleasure to be talking to
other teachers and people who are
working so effectively and importantly
with our young people and I'm looking
forward to taking some of your questions
thank you
Thank You mr. chairman and now we'll
begin taking questions the first one is
from the miami branch
good afternoon mr. chairman my name is
Tom glazier I teach history government
economics at mater Academy Charter High
School in Hialeah Gardens Florida thank
you for this opportunity here's my
question what is your view of the
current state of government budgets
local state and federal and what are the
implications for students in education
well you've identified a key example of
trade-offs which is what economics is
all about state and local governments
have been facing some fiscal challenges
for some time as you know it's not just
something that's happened since the
crisis maybe some of you're aware of a
study that just came out under the
auspices of former Fed Chairman Paul
Volcker that looked at state and local
government finances and found that many
governments are finding it very
difficult to meet their long-term
commitments for pensions and and other
benefits for their for their workforce
during the recession and the crisis of
course as the economy contracted tax
revenues fell quite a bit and states and
localities with balanced budget
amendments or requirements cut back on
their spending and indeed if you look at
employment over the last few years even
as the private sector has been adding
jobs the state and local sector has been
subtracting jobs and reducing the
overall pace of gains in our labor
market so it's been a very tight and
difficult period for state and local
governments now on the other side you
have education which is the most basic
kind of investment this investment in
human capital is investment in our
future now there's lots and lots of
evidence that every extra year of
education provides extra earning power
extra job satisfaction and adds to the
overall social welfare of the
the entire economy so there's a great
deal to be gained from from extra
education now an additional complication
is of course that the quality of
education and the amount spent on
education are not always exactly
correlated at many other factors as well
such as parental involvement community
support quality and futures types of
curriculum and so on so it's a very
complicated relationship all that being
said and understanding very well that
state and local governments while things
have been a little better lately are
still under a great deal of budgetary
pressure I hope that in making those
decisions and thinking about where to
put their limited dollars that state and
local governments will keep in mind that
we don't want to be eating our seed corn
we want to be making investments in the
future and education is one of the most
fundamental investments because it's in
our young people who will be of course
the workers consumers and citizens in
decades ahead thank you next we'll go to
Cleveland Peterson from mentor and I
teach economics to students that men are
high school and my question not mr.
chairman how does the Fed maintain the
delicate balance between not having
political party leanings or pressures
and yet at the same time offer the best
objective financial leadership for our
country it's a good question
one of the basic findings of research
about central banks is that it really
helps an economy to have a strong and
independent central bank and what I mean
by that as a central bank that can make
monetary policy and other decisions
without being influenced by short-term
political pressures the research shows
that countries with independent central
banks have lower inflation they have
more stable economies and overall more
confidence in their currency and so on
so it's very important to have that
degree of independence the reason for
this is because monetary policy tends to
work with a lag it takes time for the
full effects of monetary policy to be
felt and therefore you want decisions
about monetary policy to be made by
people who are not looking at the
short-run
being at the election a few months down
the road but are looking at the longer
term and saying what's right for the
economy so independent central banks are
very important now there's a quid pro
quo for that though we really are in a
democracy and obviously the central bank
the Federal Reserve the United States
has to be accountable has to be
transparent has to be following a
framework given to it by the Congress
and that's of course what we do we are
indeed nonpartisan we do try to make all
of our decisions based on technical
analysis based on what's good for the
economy not based on any political
considerations this is the table by the
way you're sitting here where we have
the Federal Open Market Committee
meetings and make decisions about
monetary policy and there is never any
discussion around this table about
political issues it's always about where
is the economy where is it going but
given that we are independent and there
are a lot of provisions such as the fact
that governors are appointed for 14
years for example and that the term of
the chairman goes across presidential
terms so there many provisions that give
the Federal Reserve a good bit of
independence and decision-making but the
quid-pro-quo for that is that we have to
be accountable and we are very
accountable by law I testify to I say
year in front of the house in the Senate
to explain what monetary policy is doing
and I actually testified many more times
than that our federal Market Committee
meetings are followed by a statement
three weeks later by detailed minutes we
provide quarterly projections I give a
quarterly press conference
I mean regularly with people both from
the Congress and from the administration
so I'm very responsive personally to
people in the government and so for all
those reasons we we try very hard to
make sure that we explain what we're
doing and at the end that the elected
the elected folks who are who are in the
Congress or administration can
appreciate what we're trying to do so
that's that's the balance that we try to
achieve independence in order to make
good decisions but accountability and
transparency to make that independence
consistent with our democratic framework
thank you now we'll go to Houston Alice
Purcell with First Baptist Christian
Academy in Pasadena
Chairman Bernanke what effect is the
euro crisis having on the US economy and
what would a centralized European fiscal
policy what effect would that have on
the global economy about an hour
well the European situation is very
difficult I mean the basic problem there
is that like the states of the United
States they have a single monetary
policy there's one central bank the
European Central Bank that makes
monetary policy for all seventeen
nations in the eurozone but unlike the
states of the United States they don't
have one fiscal policy each country has
its own Parliament its own prime
minister and its own fiscal policy so it
is as if in the United States during a
downturn individual states know that the
federal government is there to pay
Social Security to pay Medicare to
provide defense all those broad
government functions and each state and
locality only has to deal with its more
local services that it provides in in
Europe each country is basically
responsible for its own of fiscal
situation now since there are some
countries that are weaker fiscally and
they're involved in tightening their
belts very in a very strong way the
results of that are weaker economies in
those countries and indeed most of
Europe is now suffering a much weaker
economy on top of that their banking
system is is been stressed by the fact
that banks hold a lot of sovereign
government debt which in turn is hurting
the financial positions of the banks and
reducing the amount of lending they're
willing to do so
the European continent and particularly
the eurozone those 17 countries that
share the euro are under a lot of a lot
of economic and financial stress there's
been a lot of steps taken to try to
address that by European leaders they
have a very strong
incentive to address these problems they
want to maintain the political integrity
the the European collaboration that's
been going on now since almost since
World War two
but it is very difficult it involves
many many tough political choices the
effects of the United States are pretty
significant there are two basic types of
channels by which the euro crisis is
affecting us first Europe is a major
export destination for US firms so a
weaker European economy means that both
US exporters and exporters from other
countries are finding weaker markets and
that is reducing demand for our products
and slowing our economy probably even
more important is the fact that concerns
about the European situation have
created lots of stress and volatility in
financial markets in the stock market
and credit markets and those those
problems are affecting us here in the
United States as well so between the
financial effects and the trade effects
the European crisis is slowly slowing
our economy of course so many other
factors affecting the US economy as well
including fiscal issues credit tightness
the housing market and so on but this is
one of the European situation is one of
the factors that's slowing the the
economic recovery you asked about what
would happen if Europe had a single
fiscal a single fiscal authority that
would put them in a much closer
situation relative to the United States
that would probably address many of the
concerns many of the problems that they
have but getting to that point it's very
difficult because again you have 17
different countries and each each set of
taxpayers wants to make sure that their
own country is being fairly treated and
so it's a very difficult complex
political negotiation that's been going
on now for a couple of years okay I see
we're back at the board here but if if
we can we'd like to go to Omaha
I think Omaha's calling in hold on a
second I think you got used to there
Houston Houston do we have touch okay
I'll give it another second if not I'll
just uh pose the question or maybe what
we can do is until we get them back in
we can go to Washington DC since we have
a teacher right here in Washington DC so
let's go to DC for the next question
good afternoon mr. chairman my name is
Jennifer Walker and I teach comparative
politics and economics at Sherwood High
School in Sandy Spring Maryland my
question for you is how can we as
educators emphasize the importance of
understanding how the invisible hand led
to our current crisis while at the same
time encourage students to believe that
the market can work so I think one of
the most exciting moments in teaching
economics is when kids understand the
invisible hand idea the idea that
markets can achieve such complex
economic outcomes without any kind of
central planning Milton Friedman I think
had had the example of saying think how
complicated is to deliver a pencil you
think of all the components you know
that the wood and the rubber and the
metal and the graphite and paint and
everything else and delivery and
assembly and you get a pencil for a
dollar or whatever it is a cost and
markets can do that because the
invisible hand says that even though
each participant is working for their
own interest only and there's no central
planner involved that markets still work
somehow to deliver that that result and
indeed there's a lot of evidence I think
is pretty clear to everybody that
looking around the world that markets
have played a tremendous role in
creating the wealth that we see in rich
countries and in emerging markets that
are becoming rich so markets are an
amazing thing and
getting students and appreciate what
Marcus can do is is a very important
part of teaching economics now that
being said the next level up is to
understand that markets also have
problems that there are market failures
there's monopoly there's externalities
there's many other things that can go
wrong in markets and understanding what
how to fix those problems is really an
important key to thinking about economic
policy in general now in the financial
crisis there were a number of places
where markets or the combination of
markets and government failed
for example basic invisible hand
economics assumes that information is
perfect that everybody understands
basically what they're buying and what
they're selling that wasn't always true
obviously in the crisis when people were
buying complicated credit instruments
that contained a variety of substandard
credit products like subprime mortgages
and the people who bought that didn't
necessarily understand everything that
was in those was in those credit
products likewise during the crisis
there was huge uncertainty about you
know which banks and which financial
institutions were in danger
because it was very hard to know what
the exposures were and what what each
institution held and what the risks were
another issue related to financial
markets is that unlike most industries
financial markets are prone to runs that
is if people lose confidence in a
particular institution or even in a
broad set of institutions and they are
providing short-term deposits or
short-term funding to those institutions
they have an incentive to run and pull
out their money as quickly as possible
and if everybody does that it's like
everybody running for the exit in a
crowded theater then you know nobody's
better off what happens is that you
create huge stress in the financial
system and trying to address the problem
of runs and instability is in fact why
the Federal Reserve was created in
almost a hundred years ago to provide
support for the financial system during
periods of crisis
I finally I'd mentioned the
too-big-to-fail problem which is a sort
of a combination of government admire
kit failure institutions which are so
big and complex and interconnected that
their failure would possibly bring down
the financial system there is a strong
presumption in the markets that the
government will protect those
institutions and that means that the
market is not allowed to work in a sense
because people who lend money to those
institutions are saying well I don't
have to worry about whether they're
making good investments or taking too
much risk because I believe that if they
get into trouble the government will
protect them that obviously leads to
very bad allocations at least to
increase risk in the system so there so
to answer your question I already lost
the chance to answer your question
quickly so let me let me close by just
saying that markets are a wonderful
thing and it's important to understand
that but the financial crisis showed
there are some ways in which markets
don't always work well and you know it's
just as important to understand that
Marcus can fail as it is to understand
that markets are powerful and can give
good results a lot of the time okay now
let's see if we can go back to Omaha and
pick up from there Omaha great good
afternoon sir i'm carol mathias from
lake in North East High School economics
and current events go together so what
current offense would you consider
essential that we cover in the classroom
and as a follow-up to that after with
everything that's going on in the world
do you see any events on the horizon
that teachers should be aware of and
ready to talk with students about well
we certainly had a lot of things
happening in the economy in recent years
and I think students want to understand
you know what what they see around them
what they read in the paper what they
hear I guess they don't read paper sorry
so you know what we've seen recently
includes of course the financial crisis
a very complex event but certain parts
of it can be explained can explain what
a bank run is you can explain
the problems with the subprime mortgages
for example which ties into the
financial literacy type issues that we
talked about so financial crisis is
clearly something that kids would
probably want to understand and the
recession that followed that as well
surely they want to understand about
monetary and fiscal policy what does the
Federal Reserve what does it do house
monetary policy being used in the
current situation fiscal policy is
something that affects their lives and
quite concrete ways decisions are being
made about the long-term future of
Social Security for example who's gonna
pay who's going to benefit that has a
big effect on on on kids futures so
those are the kinds of things that can
interest them you raise that someone
raised the question just a few moments
ago about Europe that's also something
that's in the news and I know that
people are interested in understanding
what's going on there now these are all
complex issues and probably a complete
analysis is going to be tough to put
into a class but there are many elements
and aspects that you can use to try to
give a better sense of what's happening
in these situations I think going
forward there are many things you can
look at from you know there's both
microeconomics and macroeconomics at the
micro economic level issues of pollution
control and perhaps global the global
warming interest students you know what
do the economics of that what are the
economics of the demographics of our
society is getting older and what are
the implications of that for our economy
and for our young people's futures I
think an interesting question you might
think about right now is why do
countries compete to have the Olympics
in their in their country is that an
economically a sensible thing to do or
is it just for national pride basically
so there are lots and lots of issues
just you know look out look out the
window you'll find things to talk about
and see what the students were selves
raised because they've heard things on
the on them in the media
and they'll they'll raise questions
themselves thank you and now we'll we'll
go to Philadelphia mr. chairman my name
is my name is David Hill Inc I teach at
Germantown Academy in Port Washington
Pennsylvania my question for you is
about Federal Reserve System itself I'm
wondering what you think young people
most need to know about the Federal
Reserve and how it operates well the
first thing they should know is what it
is
the Federal Reserve is of course a very
important economic institution and I
think every informed citizen should know
at least the basics of what the Fed is
and how its structured and what it does
a good economics class is gonna take
students a little further it's going to
explain what what is monetary policy and
how does it work
I think a very basic thing that often
gets lost it's the difference between
monetary policy and fiscal policy the
monetary policy is responsibility the
Fed fiscal policy responsibility of the
Congress the administration those are
very different they work in different
ways and there are different sets of
responsibilities there so understanding
the distinction between those things I
think is very important the Fed is also
a regulator and the the fact that along
with other banking regulators we oversee
banks try to help control the risks that
they take and try to help maintain your
stability why is that and you know what
what economic role does that play now
all of that would probably been
sufficient a few years ago but you know
recently and now I'm getting to the AP
class a lot of other things have
happened the Fed has done things that it
hadn't done for a long time for example
over the last few years we have been
trying to use monetary policy to support
the economy but it was already almost
four years or three and a half years
since since the interest rate the
federal funds rate went almost to zero
and we've been using other kinds of
monetary policy involving the purchases
of longer-term Treasury securities for
example so instead of buying short-term
securities which is the traditional way
of doing monetary policy we're now doing
longer-term asset purchases so kids will
want to you know an advanced class or
they would want to understand how
monetary policy can be conducted even
when short-term interest rates are close
to zero the other thing which is very
important and I think there be a lot of
broad interest in this the Federal
Reserve was founded as I mentioned
before in large part to deal with
financial crises to be available to
support the financial system during
periods of panic and to try to stabilize
the financial system this dysfunction
got a lot less attention very most of
the post-war period and most people
began to think about the Fed is
primarily a monetary policy institution
but obviously with the crisis that we've
had recently and crises in other parts
of the world central banks have become
much more engaged in supporting
financial system creating financial
stability and explaining that basic
function I think is also very important
so to summarize basic structure and
governance monetary policy distinction
to be monitoring fiscal policy those are
the basics those I think of what every
citizen needs to know and then the most
recent few years the Fed has done new
things including buying longer-term
securities in order to provide more
monetary policy support and working to
stabilize our financial system those are
more complex subjects but also I think
great interest okay now we're going to
go to Los Angeles mr. Bernanke
Oh Santa Ana California and I have this
question for you what you believe is the
best way to anticipate and prevent
another financial crisis similar to the
one that started in 2008 thank you how
to anticipate and prevent a financial
crisis well
obviously given the cost of the last
financial crisis we'd like to do all we
can to anticipate and prevent and
another financial crisis and if one
happens to mitigate its effects as much
as possible I would say broadly speaking
that the the new regulatory structure is
both the dodd-frank act the Basel Accord
and other parts has really a two-part
strategy if I might the first is that we
are now taking when I say we I mean the
financial regulators the government in
general are now taking a sort of a more
system or systemic approach that is
before the crisis every regulator had
its own particular institution
particular market that it was
responsible for and nobody was there
watching the system as a whole the idea
that in fact that regulators ought to
work together to identify risks in the
broader system which is called
macro-prudential regulation was
discussed even before the crisis but it
is now I think part of what the new
regulatory structure is trying to
accomplish so we have for example
something called the financial stability
Oversight Council know lovingly around
here is f sock which is consists of 10
major regulators including the Federal
Reserve as well as some other regulators
who don't have votes including state and
local state regulators the F Sox job is
to to look at the system as a whole to
try to identify problems to see if there
are risks that may threaten the system
are their weaknesses in the structure of
the system are there gaps in regulation
that need to be addressed the Federal
Reserve has its own
Office of Financial Stability which we
created since the crisis which has a
similar function again to try to monitor
the whole system to try to identify
problems that might be arising and we
work closely with the eff sock to to
look for new problems to try to see
where there might be the next crisis
might be coming from and to take steps
to at least to provide a warning so that
we can collectively address address
those problems so that's the first part
which is to have a macro Prudential
approach which is looking at the system
as a whole is trying to identify gaps
and weaknesses and fix those if possible
now we know perfectly well that we won't
be able to identify every problem that
comes along the issues are very complex
and historically it just happens that
you know very often that neither the
private sector nor the public sector
identifies a problem until it's already
upon us so the second part of the
strategy is to make the system itself as
resilient as possible so whatever
happens even if we don't identify and/or
prevent it the system will be stronger
and able to survive and and continue to
provide credit even in the face of shock
so there are many aspects of that one
example would be the new capital
standards that have been agreed upon by
not just the United States but but
essentially all the major countries in
the world so called Basel 3 capital
standards what they would do is increase
the amount of reserves capital the banks
have very substantially and that means
is that when banks whenever whatever
might happen if banks take some
significant losses relative to where
they were before the last crisis they'll
have lots of capital which can absorb
those losses and prevent those losses
from turning into a failure or to a
broader banking panic so greater capital
stronger rules on derivatives trading
more the quiddity for banks so they have
enough cash on hand to meet withdrawals
all those things are intended to make
the system stronger so no matter what
and it's certainly going to be something
we don't anticipate the system we better
prepared to absorb the shock without
going into crisis as we saw in 2008
thank you and now now a question from
st. Louis hi my name is Jennifer Mack
lady and I work for special school
district of st. Louis County and I work
with Normandy high school math students
my question mr. chairman should the
public school system add more courses
such as economics and finance to the
curriculum so there's lots of ways to do
that I mean I think it's clearly good to
have so the beginning is really good to
have students be able to understand the
basics of economics and finance and
financial literacy but there lots of
ways to do it
I mean one way to do it is if your high
school has AP courses there are AP
courses in microeconomics and
macroeconomics and students who want to
do that can can do college preparatory
work in economics and so you can do
pretty significant pretty serious
economics courses if you want but I say
that because there are lots of other
ways to incorporate economics when I
took history in high school I said well
this is all about kings and queens and
Wars and must be other things to life
than that and of course there is
you know economics tells how people
actually live how they make a living how
societies function how markets function
trade all those aspects of history which
are so important so integrating
economics into your history inter
integrating economics into civics so
that students understand the importance
of institutions like the Federal Reserve
and regulators and fiscal policy and so
on then of course beyond that is
financial literacy which is so very
important for all students I don't think
there are any students who should not be
exposed to at least basic financial
see concepts that can be done as an
individual course as a part of a course
may be combined with something like the
Junior Achievement Program that I
mentioned which is very a good way to
get the kids interested or can be
integrated into consumer math or to a
math class or other kinds of context so
there are many ways to do it it depends
on your resources and the kinds of
interests that students have but if you
think about what people do every day
what what adults are required to do in
terms of their managing their finances
and preparing for retirement and all
those things the economics and financial
literacy are just critical parts of
Education and there are lots of ways to
incorporate it and I hope that everyone
here will do that I assume that you're
here because you're interested in doing
that and I congratulate you for that
encourage you to keep making that effort
and now we'll take a question from
Boston school in Danvers mass could you
share your thoughts on the current
crisis regarding the current level of
student loan debt and how might the burn
of currents don't student loan debts for
our young people impact the economy in
the future if these same borrowers are
not in a position to borrow for good
such as housing and automobiles or for
starting up new businesses well
student loan debt which is now one of
the largest categories of debt of any
type at this point is kind of a
two-edged sword
on the one hand education is an
investment it's an investment in human
capital and it's as I mentioned before a
very important way of increasing your
earning power and we don't want to have
a world in which talented students are
unable to get additional education
because they can't afford it so having a
student debt market or a student debt
program allows people who don't have the
money still to get the education
to benefit from that and it helps
everybody if students go on and get
additional preparation so it's very
important to have this kind of
institution now as I said it's a
two-edged sword on the other hand if
people make bad choices they can end up
being burdened with student debt large
amounts of it which is not even as you
may know you can't even discharge
student debt in bankruptcy
I mean basically you've got it so if you
acquire a lot of debt but you find that
you know the schooling you got doesn't
really prepare you for for a good job
you know then you're you're really in
trouble because you have you don't have
the income but you have the debt so what
I think I would first advise on that is
that just like any other investment when
you're investing in your own human
capital you've got to be smart you got
to make smart investments you got to
know what it is you're buying those of
you who do guidance counseling type work
think of it as being investment advisor
you're trying to explain to the student
you know what kind of job or career are
you expect to get out of your additional
education what are the graduation rates
what are the job finding rates for this
particular institution what kinds of
income can you expect to earn and does
all this make sense given how much debt
you have to take now of course that's
not the only reason people take out debt
and go get additional education there's
lots of reasons personal and other
reasons to get more schooling but if
you're thinking about it purely as an
economic proposition it's important to
understand what it is you're buying and
are you making a good investment so
counseling I think should be an
important part of the decision making
process for kids taking out student debt
because it does stick around for a long
time so in terms of the economy you know
I think the the main issues there are
really fiscal issues most government
sorry most student debt is now provided
by the federal
government and so whatever losses or
problems there may be on that side will
be fiscal problems so the losses will be
borne by the taxpayer ultimately and
they're also the issues again of
students being burdened by debt if they
don't use it in a smart way to get
themselves a kind of income they need to
pay it off so burden on future consumers
and and fiscal burdens for future
taxpayers those are some of the reasons
to try to use that wisely I don't think
that student debt is is a again you
never know but I don't think it's a
financial stability issue to the same
extent that say mortgage debt was in the
last crisis because most of it is held
not by financial institutions but by the
federal government this is Helen Roberts
from the University of Illinois at
Chicago center for economic education so
I teach all ages there's widespread
misunderstanding about how the Federal
Reserve supports the economy and the
short-run and long-run effects of
monetary policy students sometimes think
of the Fed as being in a position to
solve all economic problems and then
some also believe that the Federal
Reserve is not doing enough to fix the
economy and they blame it for addressing
problems that really are the
responsibility of fiscal policy
what do you think the Federal Reserve
needs to do to educate the public along
with us about the limits of monetary
policy so that people have more
realistic expectations your basic point
is absolutely right the Federal Reserve
is an important economic policy
institution monetary policy as well as
financial regulation have very important
roles to play in providing a stable
economy stability involving both
stability in terms of growth and
employment and stability in terms of
prices but as I've often said monetary
policy is not a panacea it doesn't saw
all problems there are many many issues
that are more appropriately dealt with
by the fiscal authorities through tax
policy or through spending decisions and
beyond that their decisions made by
trade policymakers education
policymakers all the different areas of
economic policy I think it should be a
basic part of civics or government or
whatever you know heading you put that
under that students understand that the
government is not just the Congress
administration there's all there many
other institutions including the Federal
Reserve but including regulators as well
and they have a sense of what these
institutions do and how they divide
their responsibilities I think is very
basic very basic bit of economic
education we've been sort of putting
together in this discussion two kinds of
financial and economic education is sort
of the personal type of education where
understanding better how the stock
market works may help you make better
investments and better financial
decisions but there's also the kinds of
education that involves understanding
how our society works to make you a
better citizen and a better better able
to understand what's happening in world
events and this is certainly in that
latter category a basic understanding of
modern government involves understanding
the principle economic policy
institutions and their division of labor
monetary policy again as you say is very
important it's the Federal Reserve is
the primary institution involved in that
it has the important role of providing
long term ability in prices that is a
low inflation it can be very helpful in
in helping to restore a full employment
in providing support for a recovery but
in particular the long-term types of
things like providing a strong
educational system for writing a good
tax code
creating free trade helping unemployed
workers gain skills that they need and
so on and so on there's so many of these
things which are really responsibilities
of a wide variety of economic
policymakers together with in many cases
together with the private sector working
with the private sector so I basically
agree with your point that it's
important for students to understand who
does what and what the different types
of policy can achieve thank you for that
question and now we'll go to Minneapolis
ok Minneapolis we can't hear you mr.
chairman we can hear you now mr.
chairman my name is Elam Doyle I teach
economics and government in Albany and
many of us work hard to teach the
importance of saving and investing yet
interest rates returner at historic lows
how can we teach students that they will
be rewarded for saving given that
returns that investments are currently
so low good question so obviously
interest rates are very low they're low
for a good reason I would want to say
which is that our economy is is still in
a fragile recovery and low interest
rates are intended to help the economy
recover and to restore more normal
levels of employment and growth in our
in our economy for it for savers for
investors is essential that the economy
be strong overall if you think about
what investors invest in some of it of
course is in fixed so-called fixed
income instruments like like
certificates of deposit or government
bonds but a lot of what people invest in
are stocks and and corporate debt and
small businesses and a variety of other
kinds of assets and those assets are not
going to perform well unless the economy
is strong so the kind of return that you
can get as an investor and as a saver
depends on having a strong economy and
there's really no
short cut to that and that's the reason
why we have low interest rates now as a
way of trying to restore that vitality
that will make give investors higher
returns in the future so that's the
reason that rates are low but of course
they are low that being said I think
that there's an awful lot that can be
taught even with rates being low there's
still many incentives to save if you
want to buy a house now since the
financial crisis down payment
requirements are much higher than they
were you can't get by with no down
payment in most cases if you want to go
to college and increase your earning
power if you want to retire all the many
things that people want to plan for over
there over their lives still require
saving so in fact you probably have to
save more with rates low in order to get
to a certain point and there's a lot to
be learned about it because for example
if you're going to be saving you don't
again don't want to save in just one
form you want to diversify you want to
save in different types of assets you
need to understand the trade-off between
risk and return you need to understand
how taxes affect the returns the
different types of assets so there's a
great deal to be learned about how to
save and how to invest even in a low
interest rate environment and I think
students find it pretty interesting to
have for example a make-believe
portfolio make their investments and
they can check the paper every morning
and see how they did and they may learn
that putting all their eggs in one
basket may not be the best idea and so
there many basic ideas like
diversification and risk and and risk
reduction that students can learn and
would enjoy learning ok we have one
final question and once again we'll go
to a teacher from the richmond district
who is here in the room with us so good
afternoon mr. chairman my name is Mary
Larson I'm from Oak Knoll Middle School
in Hanover
in Virginia and we hear the this
upcoming generation is going to be the
first generation of Americans who are
gonna be worse off than their parents
I'm a middle school teacher and my kids
hear this but middle schoolers think
they're invincible everything is far
away they think we're ancient so two
questions number one do you agree do you
think that this generation will not be
better off than their parents and the
second one is if your own kids were
middle schoolers today what would you
ask their teachers to do to help to
impart this important information to
them yet another very good question so
nobody can predict the future obviously
all kinds of things can happen in the
world but my best guess is that our kids
will be better off than we are and there
are a number of reasons for that the
first is that living standards depend
most fundamentally of all the various
things that determine living standards
the most fundamental is games and
productivity and we we're living in a
world of technological change and the
United States is at the forefront of
that we have we have some of the
greatest universities in the world here
and we are doing pretty well at finding
ways to commercialize the inventions and
discoveries that are coming out of those
universities in places like Silicon
Valley and Research Triangle and and in
Washington DC area as well so technology
will continue and provide new
opportunities and the US economy is well
placed to to take advantage of that we
have a very entrepreneurial culture we
have a lot of market oriented our ethos
is very market oriented we have flexible
capital labor markets there are again I
guess I would come back to one issue
which cuts both ways which is our
demographics so one of the challenges
that we face collectively is the fact
that where our society is getting older
and the fraction of people who are
retired and receiving Social Security or
Medicare is is increasing and that
creates fiscal burdens and burdens on
future taxpayers the sort of good news
is that relative to most other
industrial countries and indeed compared
even to some emerging market economies
the demographics of the United States
are actually not that bad we have a very
healthy immigration rate we have a
healthy fertility rate and so our
demographics are actually relatively
favorable compared to a number of other
industrial countries and that's another
positive so there are a lot of reasons
to think that our society will be
transformed by new technologies new
products new markets that the United
States will play an important role in
that and that will give opportunities
for our children to have higher
standards of living then then than we
did
now there's certainly some very
important challenges I already mentioned
the fiscal challenges our educational
system we need to keep improving it
because now it's it's not even a
question of it our educational system is
both failing it's failing many of our
students to some degree but it's it's
it's creating a lot of inequality also
because you have some very good schools
in the United States and some that are
very poor and that creates a very
different starting line for for kids who
are coming out of those different
backgrounds so education healthcare
fiscal a lot of issues that we have and
in a near term of course kids coming out
of high school or college right now are
not facing a particularly good job
market and that's going to make it
harder for them to get into the
workforce and the gain experience and so
on so there's lots of challenges I don't
want to deny that but again I think that
over the medium term mean even longer
term the intrinsic features of the US
economy which have made it the richest
economy in the world together with the
ongoing improvements in technology and
the strengths we have in terms of our
markets and our demography all those
things are going to be positive
now in terms of advice I think that the
way the world is going towards a more
globalized system where trade and
services can flow very easily across
borders to a highly technological
society the benefits of education are
going to get greater and greater this is
not going to be a kind of world in which
an unskilled worker is going to do well
you need to have enough knowledge enough
typically of technology but just broadly
that you can adapt and accommodate the
many changes that are happening and will
happen in coming years so the good news
for you is that your product is becoming
more and more valuable and people who
are smart will take every possible
advantage of it thank you well thank you
for all your great questions that
concludes our session for today we hope
you have gained insights from this
conversation that will help you in your
work in the field of economic and
personal finance education and on behalf
of the Federal Reserve System thank you
especially to the participating teachers
we are really pleased you could join us
today and once again we would just like
to thank Chairman Bernanke for taking
the time to speak with us today thank
you
tonight starting at 8:00 Eastern on Sea